Skyrim is back in a special edition and
it's finally here we cannot wait to go
back and murder dragons shout at people
and generally abuse every NPC available
but why do we want to go back to again
that's been collecting dust on our shelf
since 2011 with that in mind here are 10
reasons to play Skyrim special edition
the first reason straight off the bat if
you have never played Skyrim which is
one of the greatest games of all time
please do yourself a favor and sit down
for a hundred plus hours and experience
this once-in-a-lifetime game I mean
twice in a lifetime you get what I mean
anyway let's move on the mind can play
tricks on us when we think about great
games from the past we somehow upscale
them in our heads and they look a little
bit better than they actually are
Skyrim from five years ago still looks
amazing but just check out the graphical
upgrades on the special edition those
sexy visuals are only the beginning to
the texture pack included in the special
edition is actually a higher resolution
than those on PC that won't last of
course as the PC community will quickly
overhaul the visuals using mods but
we'll get to that very soon Skyrim
special edition includes all DLC
released over the years which includes
Dawnguard which focuses on an ancient
prophecy and a legion of vampires for
you to destroy or maybe join half fire
earth but I don't know how to say this
one here fire I'll go for this one lets
you become a yesteryear architect and
build a home for you and your family
it's like a mine crafting Sims crossover
which Bethesda improved and fall out for
the last DLC is Dragonborn which pits
you against another enemy equal to you
in every way
he is also Dragonborn just like you mods
we console natives are about to be
ruined by mods mods can change the look
of a game the dialog trees they where
the characters react to one another
basically mods can change everything and
anything sadly we won't get all the mods
as PlayStation have blocked external
assets which in layman's terms means we
won't get anything that isn't already in
the game so in other words we won't be
able to change dragons into Thomas a
tank
complete with theme tune - but I have
faith in the modding community and I
believe aware will be discovered to
allow Ironman to be brought into Skyrim
fingers crossed
another potential frustration is the
lack of transferable saves from ps3 to
ps4 but let's think about this a little
more why would we buy a game and not
play it from the beginning experiencing
the first time we saw a dragon will
bring back so many memories so it's okay
if you have the cash and the desire to
buy a Playstation 4 Pro you will be
rewarded with 4k visuals making the
graphical improvements from Skyrim ps3
to Skyrim ps4 even more mind-blowing
then you can invite all your friends
around and you know they will secretly
hate you for the rest of your life good
times
trophy support I bloody love trophies
and I managed to grab the Skyrim
platinum on ps3 and all those trophies
are once again up for grabs in a special
edition so if you like me and you play
games until you're absolutely sick of
them and look forward to 54 bronze 20
silver one gold and of course the
coveted platinum trophy finally improved
performance and stability let's be
honest here bethesda games are notorious
for being glitchy as heck crashing or
even taking an edge to Lord there's only
so many times you can watch the same
Lord screen before you smash your part
into a million pieces
blaming either the dog the kids on Nigel
from three doors down so just me okay we
have been reassured these minor setbacks
have been solved and we will experience
massively improved performance I say
let's wait and see shall we
to me the greatest reason to play Skyrim
is to murder dragons and absorb their
soul the perfect bit of escapism away
from school work all those little people
that sometimes fall out of your
girlfriend or wife you know I'm on about
Dhoni the ones that sometimes call you
dad anyway it's time for me to practice
my first road da boss bro da thanks for
watching please press subscribe and make
me feel all warm and fuzzy inside I'm
Adam from Playstation grenade see you in
Skyrim
you